تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثم تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدن
بوسطات دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز
الفرينه هشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل
فثمن تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من
الخرطوم في الحافله يصل الى 400 دولار
للشخص الواحد لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى محطات
وقود مغلقه اما الانقطاع الوقود او
الاستهدافها تشهد الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره
فتكلفه الجالون في السوق السوداء بلغت 50
دولارا اي عشره اضعاف السعر الرسمي
وللتنقل لابد من الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
ولا صرافات اليه والبنوك مغلقه حتى تحويل
الاموال عبر تطبيقات الهواتف لا يعمل
معضله اخرى قذائف وشظايا لم تنفجر قد تكون
في انتظار اصطياد ضحيتها لذا تشدد
المنظمات على تجنب التعامل مع اي منها
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات